Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hey, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx 2014.
And I'm here with Tor.
And we're here to talk
about, guess what?
Android tooling.
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So welcome, Tor .
TOR NORBYE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER:
You've been covering
what's new in Android in a
session on Android tooling.
And then there's
several parts to it.
Obviously, Lollipop
was just released,
but you're working on
Android Studio, which
is bringing a whole
lot of new things
to-- Android developers
to the table.
So built systems, new
features, a lot of new things.
So for those that haven't
been following, maybe
you can recap where we are.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah.
So Android Studio
is something we
announced a couple years now.
And it's a brand new IDE for us.
But it's built on top of
the rock-solid IntelliJ IDE,
so that gives you sort of very
good job editor and XML editor
to begin with.
But then we've added some
additional Android features
to make it more productive
for Android development.
And so that's sort
of the core IDE
that we're building all these
other extra tools around.
So one of the big
changes in Android Studio
is that we've added
support for the Gradle
build system, which adds a lot
of very, very useful features
for Android developers
in particular.
It makes it very easy to, for
example, with a single source
base, make your app
target have both
a free version
and a pro version.
Or you may want to
very easily create
a beta build that you
distribute to some users
and then release
build for others.
You can do that very easily.
MALE SPEAKER: So the other,
obviously-- reason you
would want to have
this is you can
run your whole build
outside of the IDE.
Not that the IDE is not good,
but there's so many more things
you can do when you're--
TOR NORBYE: Yeah.
I mean, I think it's pretty
well recognized at this point
that you want to have a
build-- you want to shape APKs
that you didn't
build on your system.
You want to have it sort of
taken from the build server,
where you're also
running your tests.
Right?
Sort of a continuous integration
server where the team sort of
commits, and it runs and makes
sure that everything is all
right.
We had a problem before Android
studio and before the Gradle
build system, where we would
implement one build system
in Eclipse, and then
we have another one
from ANT on the command line.
And so they weren't
always the same,
and it was very difficult
to target the same features.
So now we've sort
of made the decision
that there is one build system.
And it's used both in the
IDE and on the server.
And that is the Gradle one.
And then we do all this
work on Android Studio
to sort of make
that work well, so
that even though the
build system is configured
with Gradle files, you
don't have to know that.
You can sit in your IDE, open
up the product search dialog,
and say, I want to
add a free flavor,
and I want to add a pro flavor,
and I want to use this version.
You can do it all graphically.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
But if you wanted to get dirty--
TOR NORBYE: And people do.
I mean, we see a
lot of expert users.
We talk to people who
had hundreds and even
thousands of line scripts to do
all these complicated packaging
tasks.
And they can now just replace
it with small Groovy script.
And that's a big win for them.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So that's the point of
using Gradle in this case.
So Android, at this
point, is at a place
where you can target
phones and tablets.
And if we stick to that
parameter for a second--
TOR NORBYE: Phones and tablets
and, you know, watches.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
We'll get to that.
TOR NORBYE: OK.
All right.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Just
phones and tablets.
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
Only phones and tablets.
That's it.
MALE SPEAKER: No, but
that's a hard job already.
So what kind of support can
you expect in Android Studio
to help developers develop for
those different form factors?
And we'll get to wearables
and to other things.
In terms of visual tooling in
terms of hints or, you know.
TOR NORBYE: That's us.
We have a number of
features to help with this.
So I think maybe the
most easy to understand
one is that you can
view your layouts
graphically inside the IDE.
And we have this feature,
which lets you say, hey,
I want to see this
layout, but I want
to see what it's going to look
like in a right-to-left lookout
and a left-to-right
lookout at the same time.
Or I want to see
with this is going
look like across different
versions of Android,
so you can sort of see
both the Material look
and the Holo look and
even the Gingerbread look.
Or you can say, I want to
see what this layout looks
like across these
different translations.
So you can quickly see,
hey, this one language,
my strings are wrapping.
So you can sort of-- in
Android, it's very easy
to provide resources across
different configurations,
is what they're called.
Like, an example
of that would be
like landscape
versus orientation.
You can very easily say, hey,
this is my landscape layout.
This is my portrait layout.
And so we make it very easy
to sort of view all that
and see what happens to a
layout across these different--
localization, orientation,
all that stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So that in itself is
really a useful feature.
So now, of course,
if you add to the mix
the fact that we have wearables,
and the way you develop
for wear, Android
wear, specifically,
is by either the
notifications-- but if you
want to build an
app for Wear, that's
an APK that's bundled
in the other APK.
So there's a whole build
system, and Android Studio
helps for that.
TOR NORBYE: That's right.
So there actually is special
support for, for example,
Android Wear, in the
Android build system.
And by the Android
build system, I
mean the Gradle build
system that we've
extended with an
Android plug-in.
It's pretty easy.
With a small set of files, you
say, hey, this is a Wear app.
And here's some
additional parameters.
And we will actually
build all this.
We'll take care of
building the APK,
like it's bundled
in the other thing.
And we have more features
coming that makes
this even easier to target,
different variations.
MALE SPEAKER: So how about
other platforms, like Glass or--
TOR NORBYE: I think those
are all sort of the same use
case from us.
Like the IDE has certain ways
of previewing Android resources
so those can be used on Wear.
And we have special
support-- I mean,
I think one of the
challenges for Wear
is they also have the round form
factor, which is sort of just
difficult for tools
to deal with, the fact
that it doesn't
just-- like, hey,
this is not just a
rectangular window.
You have to clip
it with a circle.
But we have support for that.
And so I think
Glass and Android TV
are sort of additional use
cases, where, well, there's
this special module type
and a special plug-in type.
And you just get
to act as if it's
the exact same type of resource
from a usability perspective.
MALE SPEAKER: So
Android 5.0 Lollipop
is shipping to a number
of devices as we speak.
TOR NORBYE: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: Anything
specific in terms
of support in Android
Studio for that?
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
So there were a lot of new APIs,
obviously, in every release.
But in this release,
there's a lot of new support
to deal with animations.
And, for example,
there's vectors,
and there's ripples, and
all these new things.
And you need editor
support for that.
And we have that.
Right.
So you get code completion
in these new resource files.
We do XML validation.
So if you have a mistake,
we'll tell you that.
We'll tell you if you
are, for example, adding
a vector in a resource file
that isn't Lollipop-specific,
because that could
be a runtime crash.
So we have a lot of support
for all the new editor APIs.
MALE SPEAKER: So you have a lot
of support in terms of hints
or whatever you call those.
TOR NORBYE: That as well.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So for a
lot of different things,
not just Lollipops.
If you add those to
everything you already have,
is that the kind of information
that could be available
and generated in the
continuous build, for example?
Or is that surface-only
in the IDE itself?
TOR NORBYE: No.
This-- well, I mean--
MALE SPEAKER: For
somebody moving
to Android Studio, for example,
or moving from a different tool
chain.
TOR NORBYE: That's right.
So some of the
features are in Lint,
and those run from
the command line.
So obviously, if you're
running Lint in IDE,
you get quick fixes.
But if you run it
on the command line,
you get an HTML
report, for example.
So you can absolutely get that
in the command line server.
Some of these
features are obviously
going to be IDE-specific,
for example, code completion.
But there's also some
of these inspections,
which are running
only in the IDE.
And the reason for
that is that they're
taking advantage of a
lot of IntelliJ-specific
specific support that we can't
actually run outside the IDE.
So you definitely want
to actually try it
in the IDE as well, not
just from the command line.
MALE SPEAKER: Of course.
TOR NORBYE: Even no matter how
much you love Emacs and Vi.
MALE SPEAKER: So we are
talking about an IDE that
has not reached 1.0 just yet.
So what--
TOR NORBYE: Just yet.
MALE SPEAKER: Just yet.
OK.
Tell us more about it.
TOR NORBYE: We are
getting extremely close.
So the current version
number is 0.93.
And so, simple math,
we're 0.7 away from 1.0.
And we don't generally want
to do it that accurately.
But we are now really
kind of considering
the next few builds
release candidates.
MALE SPEAKER: So
the beta release
was back at Google I/O in June.
TOR NORBYE: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: And a number of
things changed in terms of you
couldn't allow yourself to
have block breaking changes.
What will change with 1.0?
TOR NORBYE: We've
done that anyway.
MALE SPEAKER: You've done that.
TOR NORBYE: We've
added-- our goal really
for 1.0 was to both be
stable and feature complete.
And so we, for example, have
changed the Gradle plug-in
quite a bit.
Like we've actually
changed APIs,
which were a bit
painful for our users.
That meant that
if you were using
some of these early builds, you
may have had to actually update
your build files as you got
new versions of the IDE.
We plan to stop that at 1.0.
We want to make these
APIs more stable.
And if we, for some reason, have
to change them in the future,
we'll do more work
to help migrate.
Right.
But we've also added some new
features to address feedback.
Right.
So we have a
brand-new AVD manager
that's going to try
to make it easier
to set up an AVD, a
virtual device that
is configured to run fast.
So we'll make sure
that if you're on x86,
we'll use the x86 system
image and all these things.
Right.
It was very easy in the
past to accidentally
set up a very slow emulator.
And we're trying
to streamline that.
And there's a number
of other features
we've added as well to sort
of address our 1.0 desires.
MALE SPEAKER: I have to say
I'm quite impressed to see
how many people are using
Android Studio already.
So that has to do with
the fact that it's
built on this rock-solid
base with IntelliJ.
TOR NORBYE: That's right.
I mean, let's not forget, even
though it's a 1.0 product,
it is built on
IntelliJ version 13.
It's a very, very solid IDE.
So I think the parts
that we've done
that have sort of
been tricky for us
is taking an external
build system, Gradle,
and making that work as the
build system in the IDE.
IDEs tend to be-- I
don't say control freaks,
but that's kind of how they are.
Like, the IDE knows everything.
It knows how to
build everything.
It knows what changed.
MALE SPEAKER: That's the deal.
TOR NORBYE: That
is what IDEs do.
We have deliberately
chosen not to do that,
to not have one implementation
of the build system in Studio,
and another on the command line.
We're saying, we're
always running Gradle.
And so we're working
a lot on performance
in Gradle to make-- we're not
quite where we want to be at.
I will be totally
honest about that.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
it's a 1.0 version.
Performance is never really the
biggest focus of a 1.0 version.
So maybe that's something--
TOR NORBYE: That's right.
And a lot of
editing features are
happening with that compilation.
So if you were used
to using Eclipse
or used to that-- it doesn't
update the quick fixes until we
press Save, because that's
when it runs its compilation.
IntelliJ does not work that way.
It is constantly-- the
minute you pause editing,
it'll actually go
and do its checking
and highlight errors for you.
Building is actually
when you want to run.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So 1.0 is around the corner.
Maybe by the time people
see this, it will be out.
So go out and
check for yourself.
TOR NORBYE: Depends
on how soon this is.
But definitely we're
hoping very, very soon.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, Tor, thanks a lot
for spending the time.
TOR NORBYE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: People, try
it out and send feedback.
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
Report bugs, please.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Bye.